some people in the South Pacific could
become the world's first climate change
refugees because of rising sea levels
about 100 thousand people live in the
low-lying island nation of Kiribati it's
in the South Pacific the impending
danger is the focus of the next cbsn on
assignment report when Seth Doane
traveled there he learned the ocean is
gradually overtaking the land the eacute
ervice have been here for centuries
100,000 residents who occupy stretches
of land as narrow as a basketball court
so narrow that waves from one side can
roll straight on through to the other
half of pure washes population is under
the age of 25 and some scenarios show
that within their lifetimes their home
islands could become uninhabitable
involved by the rising ocean it seems
like paradise it is a paradise what is a
paradise that we are losing tell an easy
alofa co-founded the first climate
change NGO in the country the most
disastrous thing in care of us right now
is the rising of the sea if you look
around you now you see sea walls that I
just keep on coming and taking away our
lands the sea walls back here didn't
seem to work they don't work they just
continue to be destroyed
the seawall is broken there was a
seawall here yes and now it's just
flooded with water
yes flooded with water
where was your home I home right in the
middle of the water your home was there
just been watched
yes washed away so you would have been
walking through people's homes right yes
yes who do you blame
I know they're going to hate me that's
okay America United State you can see
all of Seth dones report on the latest
edition of CBS n on assignment it airs
this Monday night at 10:00 9:00 central
on this CBS station and on our digital
streaming service CBS n